All right, let's go ahead and do the market analysis, the market research on the cities
that you chose.
And guys, again, I would recommend having a couple cities that you can look at because
you may do your research on the first one, it doesn't fit the bill, and be okay, mentally
be prepared to do 10, 15, 20 of these before you go ahead and build.
That might not be the case because we've done a lot of legwork to start off, but if it ends
up being the case, just be okay with it.
Realize that that is time well spent and that it's going to be worth it in the long run
because you're going to be able to avoid a bunch of SEO, okay?
Let's go over to the screen.
All right, so we're over here, I'm going to have you grab, there's going to be a download
with the market research worksheet.
It's also in the Facebook group, it should be here in the training as well.
Just download that, and then what I want you to do is I want you to go and make a copy.
So, you know, hit make a copy, name it however you want, I like to put the service city,
I'll remove the template and go from there.
I've already done this, I'm going to show you.
I named it Concrete, Queen Creek, Arizona, due diligence, however you're going to remember
it doesn't matter, okay?
I fill out a few basic things, Concrete's the niche, it's 52,000 people, it should be
phone driven.
I keep this here to remind you, if it's a walk in business, if it's a dentist, probably
not the niche you should be in, okay?
But just trust me on the niches I'm recommending, so yes, it's a phone driven business.
Next, what we're going to do is we're going to take our keyword list from the niche we
decided on, which as I told you guys, if you can't decide, just choose Concrete.
We're going to take those keywords and we're going to use these keywords to see what the
competition looks like, because we want to rank for these keywords long term, so we want
to see what kind of competition we're up against.
Now, there's a word of caution, do not just do one keyword, do not type in Concrete,
Contractor, Queen Creek, Arizona, do the homework on that one keyword and then make a decision
based on that, because that's inaccurate.
What I mean by that is you could potentially see a city where Concrete, Contractor, Queen
Creek, Arizona is very, very competitive, and the other four, five, six terms that you
search for, no competition, okay?
You could also see the reverse, you look at one term, oh yeah, this is going to be awesome,
next four terms, it's crazy competition, and you get your butt handed to you, okay?
So you've got to use, and guys, I didn't do this, for years and years I didn't do this
because I was never trained to do this, and I got into a lot of hot water, and this is
part of the reason I had to get rid of so many sites.
So you're going to take your list and you're going to take your core keywords.
Now, as I told you, you should only have five to seven, I don't know why we have nine here,
I'm only going to use five for this specific market research, and this is what I typically
do, okay?
So it's very, very simple, you got your document open, your market research worksheet open,
and then what I'm going to have you do before we jump in is I'm going to have you go and
go to the Google Chrome store.
If, let me say this, if you're not using Google Chrome, stop what you're doing and go download
Google Chrome.
You shouldn't be using Safari and Firefox and all these things, just trust me on this,
use Google Chrome, it's so much easier.
If you don't know how to download Google Chrome, go YouTube it, go Google it, you literally
could type in Google Chrome download, click download and it will walk you through it,
it is not hard, but if you have any problems, YouTube it, okay?
It's very simple, there's videos on everything, it's amazing and it's free, okay?
Go download Google Chrome and then what I'm going to have you do is inside of Google Chrome,
I'm going to have you type in Google Chrome store.
You're going to go to the Google Chrome store, click on the first link, and I'm going kind
of fast guys because I want to focus on the market research, not on all the little baby
steps here.
This is very simple stuff, Google Chrome web store, you're going to type in SEO Quake,
this is what is called an extension, okay?
It's free, type in SEO as in search engine optimization, Quake as in Quaker Oats, click
on it, click on this one that has the green, SEO Quake, and then it's going to say add
to Chrome, mine says remove because I've already added it, okay?
Click add to Chrome, that's it, and then what's going to happen is you're going to go back
over here, you're going to see this little guy right here, it might not show up in the
top so you might have to click this puzzle piece and underneath it you'll have to click
on this thumb tack and turn it blue, that means it's going to be pinned to the top of
your search bar so it's really easily accessible, I would recommend doing that and then it should
show up like this.
And that is all the setup you need so have your market research worksheet ready, have
your SEO Quake, have your keywords ready, and let's freaking shake and bake baby.
So now what you're going to do is you're going to go to your keyword list and you're going
to take your top five keywords and you're going to start plugging them in with the city
and state, so concrete, Queen Creek, Arizona, concrete contractor, Queen Creek, Arizona,
concrete company, Queen Creek, Arizona, concrete patio, Queen Creek, Arizona, concrete driveway,
Queen Creek, Arizona, and then I always like to throw in a little curve ball and I like
to take the first one, the main term, concrete, Queen Creek, Arizona, I like to take the city,
and I like to switch it and search it, so Queen Creek, concrete, okay, beautiful.
So now we've got five terms to look at and we're going to go and what we're going to
look at now guys, we're going to look at which companies show up in the map section over
and over and over for all of these terms because these are the terms that get the most search
volume guys, realize, like I hope you guys are following along, these terms that we decided
on, these have the most search volume nationwide.
Now we want to see in the specific city we're looking at what companies are showing up for
those terms, those are our competitors and then we want to look at those competitors
and see what kind of work are they doing, are they competitors because they're good,
are they competitors because there's no one else in the market, that's what we're looking
for is those cities where people are in the top spots by default, not because they're
doing something special, okay, so all we're going to do now is we're going to start looking
at common allies, so I'm going to start off with Bowman, Bowman shows up for number one,
Bowman shows up for number two, Bowman shows up for number three, Bowman shows up not for
number four, shows up not for number five, shows up for number six, so four out of six
I'm choosing Bowman and so what you're going to do is you're going to right click or you're
going to push command if you're on a Mac, you're going to open their website, you're
going to copy and paste this sucker over here into this sheet, so you're going to put it
once under the citations, once under the backlinks, once under the content, once under the domain,
let me explain this, the reason we are doing specifically looking at the citations which
I'm going to explain, the backlinks I'm going to explain, the content I'm going to explain
and the age of domain I'm going to explain is because these are the main factors when
it comes to ranking a website organically and in the maps and so those are the things
we want to look at, we don't care what their logo looks like, we don't care how much they
have, how many, I don't know, customer testimonials, those things don't affect ranking, we care
about how old is their domain, how much content do they have on their website, how many backlinks
they have and how many citations, I'm going to show you how to find all of them and what
they mean, how we can interpret them but for the sake of this what I want you to do is
go and find the next three companies that would fit inside of here that show up for
the majority, so if you have six terms that you're searching, one, two, three, four, five,
six, I want to know the company that shows up at least four out of six times, minimum.
Now if you start seeing and there's not any commonalities and there's different companies
every single time, that's actually a good thing, that means there's no steady, like
somebody that Google can rely on and so don't stress it, if you can't find anyone that shows
up for four out of six, find someone that shows up for three out of six and just don't
overthink it.
Another thing I want to point out is when you see the following which I have found,
this is my favorite thing, this is why I'm talking a little fast, getting a little excited
but when you see what I'm about to show you, you have found some freaking gold my friends
and what that is is you have a company like this, Copper Star Concrete LLC dash Steve
Wood, shout out to Steve, okay, you got Steve over here, homeboy does not have a website,
no website, it's 2022, he's ranking number one, question is does he rank for every single
search term or at least the majority, if he does, we have found some freaking gold baby.
Okay, so let's go to the first one, there's Steve, one out of one, there's not Steve,
so one for two, oh no, no there's Steve, two for two, there's Steve, three for three, Steve's
four for six, Steve made the cut guys, Steve's five for six, the only one Steve does not
rank for is the last term, throw Steve on the sheet guys, let's freaking rock and roll,
what you're gonna do here is you're just gonna copy his thing, like his whatever and you're
gonna go over here and boom, boom, I didn't even copy it, maybe just put like, you can
just put Steve, it doesn't matter, like you're just, you're literally just acknowledging
that this guy does not have a website which is absolutely asinine, I love it, it makes
me happy because what that means guys is Google, you gotta realize, Google's literally saying,
look at this, okay, Google's saying to me as a homeowner, because they think I'm a homeowner
I'm looking, right, I think I'm a customer, they're saying, hey Mr. Homeowner, you're
looking for concrete, well here's Steve, he's one of the top three choices in town, sorry
he doesn't have a website, you know, all that stuff, but he's your best, he's one of your
top three choices, that is garbage, that is absolute garbage, what that shows me is there's
a lack of competition and I love that, so if you guys see this, a web, sorry, a listing
that shows up for four out of the six or the majority of the terms, okay, have at least
five or more, and they do not have a website, you can almost guarantee this is gonna be
a yes, okay, almost guaranteed, I would even like venture to say it's a yes immediately,
but I'm gonna keep doing this, okay, so we're gonna add Steve and then we're gonna add another
one and then what we're gonna do guys is we're gonna go and find the information that's necessary,
so we're gonna find the citations, we're gonna find the backlinks, we're gonna find the content,
we're gonna find the domain, okay, the age of the domain, so what you're gonna use is
this SEOquake tool and all you're gonna do is go to their site, so remember how I opened
old Stevie's site, okay, inside of Steve's site this SEOquake tool should be showing
up, if it's not you need to go over here and it's probably toggled off, you need to make
sure that SEOquake is enabled and then you should see this, okay, if you don't it'll
typically show up underneath here as well, see how it's added it here, so you could actually
see it in the organic listings as well, it'll tell you L, that's the backlinks, it's gonna
tell you, where's the G, I'll have to show you another way to do this as well, it's not
showing the G which is the number of pages, the Google thing which I can show you a different
way of doing that, but very simply this one right here it says NA, why, because this isn't
even a real website, this is a WW1.bomanarchitecture, this is garbage, okay, so I'm gonna go and
I'm gonna put, you know, content, NA, because it doesn't even make sense, okay, I'm gonna
go back, L, that's number of backlinks, zero, I think you guys are seeing what I'm seeing
here right, zero, backlinks, boop, zero, awesome, domain, now the way that you're gonna go ahead
and find the domain, you used to be able to go like this and inside of SEOquake you could
click on the who is and then you could click I'm not a robot and you could click go, I
wanna show you something that's really funny based on what I said on another video, come
on baby, spinnin', let's go, okay, actually you can do this, it depends on the website,
you can do it this way, you're gonna scroll down and you're gonna look for, it says too
many requests, let's see, right here, created on 2018, it's 2018, boom, if this isn't working
for some reason, you can also go to something like duplichecker.com, just type in how to
find age of domain and you'll find something like that, but you just wanna find out what
year the domain was put live, what year the website went live, okay, and that's all you're
gonna do and then you're gonna do the citations, now the citations you're gonna go to something
called Whitespark, you can literally type in Whitespark.ca, you can get a free account,
so Whitespark.ca and you're gonna go and once you create a free account you're gonna hover
over this, right here, you're gonna hover over local SEO software, it's kind of a hover
and then go over to local citation finder, okay, and what you're gonna do is you're gonna
try it free, thank you SEO White Spark, okay, you're gonna try this free and you're gonna
go over to searches, not campaigns but searches and then you're gonna go and type in new search,
okay, let me make sure I got this right, new search and you're gonna toggle this to business
search, and what we're gonna do is we're gonna go and I've already done Bowman so I'm gonna
do old Steve, I'm excited to see how many Steve has, old Copper Star Concrete, you're
gonna click on it and you're gonna copy this exact thing, okay, boom, we're gonna come
back over to Whitespark, business name, copy and paste, exactly, I know it looks janky,
it is janky, copy it exactly, okay, go back, copy the number, exactly, okay, Steve Wood,
you know what's crazy about this, this guy has a 435 number, guys, this is a, you know
this 435 is an area code that I have, that is insane, that is, well I did have, this
is a Utah area code, I'm loving everything I'm seeing about this, okay, so copy and paste
it, sorry I'm a little bit behind here, boom, city, Queen Creek, autofill, AZ and push,
create search, this is gonna take a minute and it's going to spit out a result and it's
gonna give us the number of citations and we're gonna have this, so I want you guys
to do this for all of the three different people that you have found, so you should
have three, now, if you go through and it's Helter Skelter, there's only one that's consistent,
one of them has no website and the third one it's like, it's just like, there's no commonality
amongst all of your search terms, for example, you know, you can't see the same person showing
up twice, what I would do is I would go and dip into the organic and I would choose the
first company that's an actual company, not a home advisor, not an Angie's List, not
a BBB, but a company, so rock solid in this case, I would choose them and I would put
them right here and I would probably skip a row and put them under here, you know, copy
and paste it, I didn't even grab the domain, and I would say, you know, no consistent third
option, and then I would grab this guy, wherever he's at, and I would just go ahead and put
him here, oh boy, sorry, I'm in the wrong one, I've got to go right here, cool, I'd
put him here, I'd put him here, I'd put him here, and I would do the homework on this
one because there's just not three competitors, that also is a good sign, okay, so what I'm
gonna do here guys, I'm gonna pause this really quick, I am going to finish this worksheet
without making you guys watch me do it, I'm gonna come back, we're gonna assess it and
determine whether Queen Creek is a go or not, I can tell you right now it's already a go
because of Mr. Stevie Boy, okay, so give me one second, guys, here we go, I've got this
thing completed, I'm just gonna go through it really quick, so the companies I chose
was Bowman, Desert Installations, they were a company that kept showing up over and over
and over, they don't show up in the first term, but they showed up a ton, so I chose
them, and then the third one was Steve, which was that copper star concrete LLC Steve, and
yeah, that's what's interesting about this, so obviously if you look at this, I did all
the stuff I told you to, I found the backlinks for Desert Installations, they had two backlinks,
they had one page of content, their domain was 20-20, and then of course on Steve, there
was no backlinks because he didn't have a website, there was no content because he doesn't
have a website, and his domain was NA because he doesn't have a new website, so it was really
easy, okay, so how do we look at this, how do we assess it, I also found the citations
for these other companies, as I told you, this will spit you back a number, and you
just wanna list this number right here, and we can get into citations later, basically
just so you guys know, citations is the name, address, and phone number of the listing,
so for example, this right here, Bowman Concrete, this address, this phone number, it's the
domain, address, phone number, they call it the NAP, it's how many places around the internet
that exact matched NAP, exact matched NAP or NAP is listed around the internet, so places
like, yo, places like Facebook, places, they call these directories, they call these citations,
and it's listed exactly, so for example, Copper Star is listed in 14 places, exactly the same,
okay, Desert Installation, 11, and Bowman, 46, okay, honestly, I don't pay too much attention,
but it is nice to know when you start doing citations, which we're gonna get into later,
so how do we interpret this, well, the only other thing I like to do is once I do this,
I wanna know, okay, Bowman, you dirty dog, I wanna know where you're ranking, so for
example, on this first term, I wanna see if Bowman's on page one, no, no, no, not on page
one, okay, what about the second term, looking for Bowman's website, remember Bowman's website
here, which is an absolute junker, let's go ahead and grab it, if you wanna remember it,
Bowman Architectural, nope, nope, nope, nope, nothing, not on that one, okay, I'm looking
to see how many of these top three are actually showing up on page one, none, none so far,
okay, Bowman is not showing up for one term on page one organically, okay, nope, nope,
nope, I'm even on page two, nothing, okay, guys, this is a layup, I'm telling you right
now, it's a layup, and I have no plans of going into this, so the first person to watch
this video, if you wanna go grab this, this is a freaking layup, so check this out, let
me look at this last one, just in case, Bowman, where you at, dog, nope, so, no Bowman, so
what I'm gonna put here, I'm gonna go over and I'm gonna say, not ranking page one organic,
any terms, boom, now we're gonna go look at desert installation, and by the way, I already
know this, they're not ranking because I've looked, by the way, just to save the time,
desert installation is not ranking on page one for their website either, okay, so I've
already done it, they're not, so, and then Steve doesn't have a website, no website,
so how do we determine, how do we interpret this, well, here's the question, does this
niche look like low-hanging fruit, yes, and I'm not kidding you, I'm gonna stab about
six of these, 20 of these, 30 of these, I'm pumped about this niche, yes, now here's the
reasons why I'm excited, number one, Steve, who's a top competitor in the maps, does not
have a website, therefore he's not ranking on page one, therefore he's not a threat,
Steve is not doing well, and he is one of the top companies in Queen Creek, number two,
the other companies in here, for example, Bowman Architectural, well, number one, they're
like an architectural company, we wouldn't have that in the domain, number two, their
website is weird, they have no backlinks, it's just a weird site, it's not a traditional,
there's nothing, there's no content, it sucks, okay, and on top of that, they're not ranking
on page one, which is beautiful, and then desert installations, it's a brand new website,
if they're new, that's better for you, it means they're easier to outrank, Google, just
for the record, they like older websites, to Google, an older website means it's a company
that's gonna be in business for a lot longer, it's a more trusted company, and that's what
they like, so the fact that these are both newer websites really makes me excited, desert
installations also does not show up on page one, what this tells me is, guys, Google is
searching for somebody to put in the top spot in the maps, and in the organic, and no one
is doing what they want, no one's proving to Google, hey, I'm the guy, I'm the girl,
I'm the website, I'm the company, you should use me, you should put me at the top, they're
not doing anything correctly to incentivize Google to put them at the top, and therefore
there's a lack of options, and Google is putting some garbage companies, okay, there's probably
good companies that do work in Queen Creek, but they don't know what they're doing online,
so what that allows us is an opportunity to come in with our freaking ninja tricks, build
a website, rank that sucker really rapidly, and capture those leads, and why does this
matter if we're gonna run ads, and we're gonna get the client first, because guys, if you
wanna do this long term, and you wanna rank this organically, you wanna see what kind
of work you're cutting out for yourself, right, because once I get the deal, now I'm gonna
go to work, now I'm gonna build a website, now I'm gonna do the content, and the backlinks,
and the whole deal, and I don't wanna get into a dog fight, I wanna make sure that we're
good, when I get the deal, I don't have to do that much work, guys, once I get a deal
in Queen Creek, build this website, or one of you does, this website with some decent
SEO is gonna rank in a matter of a couple of months, if not a couple of weeks, which
means you're gonna be able to turn off the ads almost instantly, so this thing is gonna
be a cash freaking cow if we can find somebody that will take these leads, that's already
paying for leads, et cetera, so I just want you guys to understand, when you're doing
these things, take your time, if it is not an overwhelming yes, okay, and by the way,
this is kind of like a really extreme example, you don't come across these all the time,
that's why I'm talking so fast, I'm so pumped, but I want there to be no doubt in your mind
that this is going to be easy to rank, I do wanna mention one last thing, is if you see
that every company in the map, so let's say the top three companies, which in this case
was Bowman and Desert Installations and Copperstar, if you see that all three of those companies
that you've determined are the top three consistently, if they're all showing up on page one organically,
which again is below the maps, if you see that, run, that is not somewhere you wanna
be, that is a very competitive niche and city combination, so again, if all the competitors,
the top three people, after looking at all five terms, those three people are showing
up for the majority of the terms on page one organically, that's underneath the maps, run,
this is not worth your time, there's other cities and niche combos out there that are
gonna make, it's gonna make way more sense, it's gonna be way easier to rank, and you're
gonna make, you're frankly gonna make way more money, so for this one guys, I'm telling
you, this is an absolute freaking yes, I'm gonna build the landing page, I'm gonna run
the ads, I'm gonna get the deal, and we're gonna freaking get a website crankin' really,
really fast, I'm gonna lower the ads, and I'm gonna put some cheddar in my pocket, baby.